e
I will call the meeting to order for
July 10th for the fiscal committee and
not that we have a replacement for
representative walner representative
Heath is on the house side to replace
her and while we're all here I thought I
would mention that two of our longterm
colleagues has lost each lost a son Mark
mcon and Bruce
berky
so ask that we rise and give a moment of
thank
you okay item number one is the Youth
Development Center claims Administration
and settlement fund we have Jennifer
Foley here if anybody has any questions
item thank you for
coming good
morning does everyone understand the
item and and uh have any questions
Senator rosenal thank you very much Mr
chairman um I understand the item but I
don't really understand is why the
administrator needs to pause the claims
process for two two
months so could you please explain
CL is that good
okay um sure happy to answer that so we
um put a temporary hold in place that
actually is in somewhat it's partial U
so we are there are areas of claims
processing that is continuing um and
there is areas of payment processing
once we got over the fiscal year change
over that are continuing um so the
temporary hold is on some portions of it
but not all of it um and the reason for
the temporary hold is we have uh legal
documents that need to be changed due to
the statutory changes there's
significant you know substantive and
procedural um changes that the Senate
Bill 591 put in place so we have to take
those forms down we have to take the
claims processing document um the claim
form itself the valuation guidelines all
those set of legal documents that joint
fiscal is required to approve um for us
to move forward with under the new
statute that applies to pending and
unresolved claims and also all new
claims are coming to us so that's one of
the primary reasons is that we we are in
a transition
period follow up thank you but then that
bill was
signed some time ago yep um how long
does it take to for you to do that yep
work y so um the bill was signed on June
14th um so part of the work let me give
you just sort of the pockets of work
that we're doing right now um one is
assessing which of the claims in front
of us um are in the pending and
unresolved State um the new claims that
are coming in um to make sure we're sort
of doing an appropriate inventory um as
to and some claims were close to being
resolved award letters had gone out and
so we needed to assess and we are
assessing which claims are in somewhat
governed under the old um former statute
right so we're kind of making that
inventory that's one area of work that
our staff is doing uh another area of
work is the legal documents that need to
be revised that involves uh folks Beyond
administrator bradrick so we have
representative we attorney general
design is present with us today Laura
Raymond um who is um who's taking the
place of Jennifer Ramsey the AG
designate and the Attorney General's
office um is um has essentially the
charge of making sure that set of legal
documents is revised appropriately under
the statute is getting the input um
needed from claims Council and also from
our office and we're also teaming up
actually there's about four or five
significant legal documents that takes
you know lawyers and others to get
involved from both of our offices to
work together and to coordinate um and
so I don't want to get ahead of Laura
Raymond speaking to what process the
Attorney General's office is doing but
we're having a series of meetings um
just yesterday I got another legal
document to look at and to get back to
the Attorney General's office by Friday
I also gave them a legal document so
we're we're it it takes that time to
make sure that um the the new statute
the the new revisions are appropriately
applied and then brought to Joint fiscal
I believe August 16th is the next time
joint fiscal meets and advance that
meeting we'll be getting those revised
legal doc documents for Joy fiscal to
review um and and hopefully approve um
relatively quickly so that we can go
ahead and apply those new stat those new
itself good and maybe this is really a
question for the Attorney General's
reports seem like the plaintiffs or the
CL payments let's say are not really
getting the full story on what the
revision to the statute does so it seems
like they're not getting the information
that if they're getting a multi-year pan
they'll also be getting 5% interest
every year and so I'm wondering who who
between the administrator and the AG
will be explaining clearly on a
website what the changes are to this
statute and and what the true story of
the multi-year PS is is will that be the
administrator's office or that or will
that be the AG that's that's a great
question so transparency is our top
priority we understand that um making
sure that there is um clear information
um publicly available so that there's
stability in the system and stability in
the fund and people are confident that
the the appropriate work is being done
and done on time so that we can you know
resume all claims processing and all
Payment Processing as quickly as
possible so we um once the uh we want we
monitored when the bill U was signed the
Attorney General's office told us right
away um we posted those changes on our
website immediately so on our website
the very opening paragraphs um explain
that um this change is in place um the
chapter version of the bill was posted
on our website um immediately um we do
um from as a a neutral standpoint um we
do um strike the balance between um we
need to explain to um claims Council
what the statute means and says um
versus they are I mean I'm not trying to
be cute in this but they are lawyers and
and and with the statute being posted on
our website they are knowledgeable about
what about the 5% interest um I think
the the place that um our office is
working very hard to be transparent with
is getting um we get out guidelines um
that are they're not joint fiscal
guideline joint fiscal approved
guidelines they're more like guide posts
I suppose that give a little more plain
speaking or Layman's explanation right
and so um we want to make sure we're
coordinating carefully with the Attorney
General's office and with claims counsil
to make sure that the expression our lay
person expression um is um in line with
all expectations um so that is something
that will be posted on our our website
those those are part of the forms um and
the instructions um and the guide posts
that we are working on revising now um
and I believe it's next week that the
Attorney General's office is hosting in
a listening session with all with with
claims Council um where there there
there'll be you know we need to hear
where any areas of confusion are so we
can make sure that the forms that we
revise are satisfying that confusion and
we have a maximum input so that we can
make sure our instructions and forms
give the lay persons um expression thank
you most hear you
br sure yep did you want me to um repeat
anything no okay all right
representative lean for a question
followed by Senator Dallas Andro
representative lean is recognized thank
you Mr chairman and thanks for being
here this may be a question more
appropriate for the representative from
the Attorney General's office but you
mentioned there are new claims coming
forward apparently you know they keep
adding up there's hundreds and hundreds
of claims and complaints where do things
stand I think there are only like 10 or
11 people that have been indicted so far
how is that side of this whole thing
going and again probably the question
for the representative from the Attorney
General's office yeah you're right that
question would be for for the Attorney
General's office in terms of asking the
status of criminal indictments that
that's the claims process office is not
part of that
thanks senator dallesandro for a
question thank you Mr
chair just a a quick two questions what
is the attorney general
Attorney General's office prosecutes
defends and then makes decisions that's
a triple header right they prosecute
those who are criminally intent they
defend the State against this and then
make make decisions how does all of that
work and my second question is I've had
an individual come to see me who who
claims this is he was a recipient now
who claims that he wasn't fully
uh he wasn't fully given all of the
information that he he he thought was
required he he settled he settled he
said he signed this document he show he
signed the document for 400 something
thousand he thought he was going to get
2.5 billion and the real
real problem there real problem and I I
did speak with the administrator about
it it
uh that problem
seems to have been reoccurring how do we
solve
that so
um in terms of getting information to
folks um along the way of the process um
I can speak to that portion of it in
terms of what the caims processing
office um seeks to do y um and we
certainly do our level best to give
people information in advance of them
needing to make critical decisions in
the life about whether they're going to
accept an award withdraw from the
process or however they are choosing to
engage with the process and we get that
information to them in advance um you
know whether um they're personally
receiving um the the the uh help that
they may need as individuals next to
them um to translate the information
because even like a lay person's
description on our website can be I
think sometimes hard for clim understand
um or the and there's another example
the waiver and release forms that are
obviously very important forms to um
read and understand and digest uh before
you choose to an accept an award you
know I we're not going to speak to the
Attorney General's office because
they're in charge of those forms but in
my working side by side with them um I
see that they work also very hard to
have as much as possible um in a legal
process a uh lay person's description um
what else can we do we can keep um
hearing it's very important for us to
hear areas of confusion so we can go
back to those forms during this revision
process and say is there a way we can do
better is there a way we can um give a
more clear expression um we have a lot
of people that gives us input let me
give you an example if I could um from
the beginning we hired trauma-informed
experts um that are non- lawyers uh
which can I think can be a very
important part to have part of any
communic ation process with claimants to
read our forms in advance of us um
putting them into the process in live
fashion um I work you know uh with with
folks every day is saying okay this is
my lawyer perspective now I go along to
my staff who has different experience in
different areas including my trauma and
form experts read those forms and say
have we have we met the balance where
the legal expression is there um but
it's also as much lay person as possible
even early on in the process we had um
commissioner Hanks review um some of our
frequently asked questions um because we
know uh we don't have the perspective of
those who are um residents of Department
of Corrections and you what kind of
educational level um language we need to
use so that's that's a something we
Endeavor to do um every day all the time
when we're revising forms um is to try
to strike that balance um whether we
always hit it we love to hear the
feedback
um I often get calls um from press and I
say hey I would love it if you would
review our website and review our
frequently asked questions and let us
know where it's confusing um and I have
folks sit with me in the room and take
down the notes that press is asking
because I could say they are our best
litness test as to whether things are
clear or confusing um but it does take
time that once I hear that we still have
to go back to the documents and say okay
where can we make some tweaks sure okay
appreciate that yeah I I I did I did
contact the administrator discuss this
with the administrator maybe some of you
also got these calls but I get a call
from a guy who says I'm ready to commit
suicide because that uh the deal that I
made wasn't exactly what I thought it
was going to be and as a result of that
uh I'm living in a car I I can't do this
I can't I I can't do that and uh I'm
ready to take my ready to take my
life mean I don't like getting those
calls obviously and I can't solve it not
I can only refer back to you or to the
administrators as to to what's to what's
kind of going on here I I I don't know
how many of these kinds of circumstances
have developed when legislators have
been involved but I know in my case I've
had those calls yeah yeah I I think
we've done everything we we can here at
the legislative level to make things
better for all of these people you know
we did the initial the initial bill we
got a secondary bill because we found
out that there were problems with the
original piece of legislation and Asos
well point it out they are not getting
the shaft by having an extended payment
schedule they're getting paid uh for
that there there's there's an
interest that's paid if the uh payout is
is elongated so I I just I just worry
about this whole the whole situation to
be honest with you I thought it was
going to be a lot smoother uh and I'm
very worried about it that's all I
passed that on to you and I appreciate
the kind of work you you guys are doing
but uh there's I think there's trouble
in the bubble and that's that's all I I
want to make that point Thank you thank
you Mr
chairman representative Edwards for
thank thank you Mr chair this kind of a
question to you g given that this is a a
fairly straightforward request to hire
one assistant administrator and there
are so many questions I I I wonder if we
should schedule an information briefing
at some point for the fiscal committee
so that the rest of these questions
could be explored I I have questions
that I'm not asking because it's not
now's the opportunity we we're not on a
tight schedule here today and if you uh
and I'm hoping the Attorney General's
person comes back cuz I know some of you
have questions for that person
so so so in that case I have a question
but it's for the Attorney General all
right so and and I think some of us also
had questions for the attorney general
and don't know what happened to her Mr
chair cruset from the L's office the
representative from the Attorney
General's office had to leave so there
will be nobody here for the rest of this
meeting from their office I believe on
the 16th when uh is the intended date
the fiscal is to meet again and at that
time the revised documents would come
forward the Attorney General would be
here for that as well so I don't know if
you want to kind of make that a meeting
where you focus some of these questions
or if you want something before that no
there's there's something that that
people have asked me why isn't there a
lie detector test for these things that
keep coming up and know happened to me
thousands of times and so on so forth
and and uh you
know we we we're not relying on that at
all seems like the lie detector test
would would prove how many people are
lying or they've been coached by the
lawyers or whatever and you know there's
a lot of Suspicion of all this and and
I've read in the paper somebody borrowed
160,000 based upon the fact he thought
he was going to get a lot of
money and and somebody loaned him that
money based upon the fact that oh yeah
you're going to get a lot of money out
of this this deal and so you know this
this is troubling
so you know I thought she would stay
here so we could have some conversations
about this um I oh she had oh I'm
sorry it seems to me that that this is a
pressing issue yes why would the
Attorney General
leave yeah what else was more important
yeah what else exactly we're talking
about the lives of of deip Citizens
We're talking about a a lot of resources
that we're expending in order to to to
do to do this and we have we have
questions people have questions on the
board that that they'd like to bring
forward and uh help the next opportunity
would be a month from now yeah that
doesn't make any sense to me just
doesn't make any sense what we will do
is send all our questions to Mike Kane
and he will forward them to the attorney
general so they will be ready to give
some answers because I want to know why
we're not doing a lot detectors okay you
know and we all want to know why haven't
prosecuted more people why haven't they
identified more of these people that
have been doing the abuse and can we get
some number out of them because the two
numbers on the both sides don't make
sense 100,000 people are all going to
put in claims that they were abused on
by a handful of employees it makes no
sense
so represent you have a question for the
administrators what's that I do have a
um does your office have a
projection for the administrative cost
for the next fiscal year that will be
drawing out from the
fund um so administrative costs um in
terms of from our office are also
including the Attorney General's um from
your office yes which was about 2
million in the last fiscal year um thean
the answer is yes um I don't have that
number in my mind right now I can get it
for you we did put together um an
operating budget um to put in front of
the Attorney General's office um and so
that we could all sort of be on the same
page as to what are projected costs and
expenses um we have um brought in uh
folks with um a lot of financial
experience in terms of being able to
monitor the fund carefully and project
expenses monitor actual expenses as the
months go forward in order to have a lot
of financial transparency for for for
joint fiscal uh we've had um several
meetings with the Attorney General's
office um and representatives there to
prepare for that so that for this next
um joint um the next appropriation um we
are accounting for anticip anticipated
expenses from both of the office offices
plus um what the awards are going to
look like um that come from both
administrator broad's final decisions
that are accepted and also we um
anticipate that there will still be some
stipulated agreements or settlement
agreements that go directly with the
Attorney General's office that um also
run through the claims process and come
from the fund so all of those four
buckets we are um doing the best we can
to get um uh that we've done some actual
projections and then actual watching on
a monthly basis is of what the impact on
the fund is Mr chairman can I ask that
we request that we all see that
budget very good send send all this send
all these questions to the LBA we'll
forward them to the uh the attorney
general I'm hopeful that we can move
forward in this process by approving
this request and then obviously we'd
have to come back because of changes and
if we in the room we send all our
questions to the attorney general it may
affect what he come back to us with a
proposal in about a month so I'm hoping
we can do that I wish we had the
Attorney General here now but in in lie
of that we'll I'll send questions
forward uh so I would entertain a motion
to adopt the item so that this can
begin I I would also move the item um
but if I could just say say something Mr
chair so a little disappointed that
there's a hold for two months on um
paying any of the claims I think it's
not the best look but I guess first
question um it will be ready by the 16th
with any of the rule changes that we and
fiscal need to approve yes okay um
so I would also say that there were
extensive hearings on my bill Senate
Bill 591 which made these
changes um the Attorney General did
testify in front of the Senate I'm
assuming he testified in front of the
house um but given the magnitude of
potentially a thousand claims and the
average cost of
$500,000 I think um the legislature is
going to be in the business for quite
some time of having to fund these
settlements so it would be helpful for
the Attorney General uh to be able to
testify but he is I I I also have to
defend the Attorney General he's been
pretty upfront um with at least those of
us in the Senate and I'm assuming in the
house um going back to you know when my
good friend Karen umberger introduced
her bill a couple of years ago and and
um I think he's taken the lead on trying
to resolve this issue and has done a
done a really admirable job but you know
like anything else a lot of money at
stake so we need to keep a watchful eye
on it but uh we're not going to be able
to move forward if we don't approve this
position today so right having said that
I hope we can all vote to approve this
position thank you all right
representative Edwards moves Senator
Bradley seconds to adopt the item
further discussion seeing Nani ready for
the question all in favor say I I oppose
no the item is adopted thank you do do
you mind if I clarify a couple of
items thank you um Payment Processing um
was um the first thing put on hold um
and has started to continue so as of
yesterday um
probably at least 10 went forward um
that were award letters that were
accepted in lumpsum um and under the
former um statute um that were put on
hold to get through the fiscal year um
changeover um those did go forward
yesterday um also what went out
yesterday to um claims Council was um uh
basically a call for information on the
um periodic payment um uh question
uh so the there's a a whole series of uh
final decisions that are sitting on my
desk that cannot go out until the
administrator makes a decision about
whether it's a periodic imp payment or a
lump sum under the new statute so uh we
sent out um a a request to those Council
that have those claims to get its
information by the middle of August um
that would so that the administrator can
go ahead and make um that discretionary
decision um so some of payment
processing is on hold simply because we
need to get the information to the
administrator um so that he can make the
type of payment um so I just wanted to
clarify that um I'm also aware that Miss
Raymond had a um a court date at 10:30
which is why she needed to to leave um
so there wasn't anybody else that could
come I can't speak to I can't speak to
that um but I just wanted to at least um
clarify that but appreciate that um is
not a good look for the state to see all
these people coming forward with all
this abuse and the fact nothing was done
for
decades so when they when they put a
further delay on it's oh cover up you
know and all this other stuff this this
is not a good look for the state and and
we're all working hard to make this the
best state and it it falls on us to say
what did you do about it you know this
kind of thing and obviously people are
very attuned to get a hold of the senior
senator here because they know he'll get
things done so he's getting calls from
all over and saying what are you doing
about this you know and it's not a good
look yes and and we have to do our best
to move this forward and show that we're
being fair and we're doing something but
the fact that so few people have been
charged with crimes and it took so long
to get it to this point these things are
all very negative looking for this for
state government and we're all upset by
it and we're ready to move forward by it
but we have to have some things done
that have a good appearance that really
something is being done and it's not
being pushed away it's not being delayed
it's not being trying to shove it aside
and plus the greed of the lawyers is is
coming to light too the fact that you
know 33 and A3 per of hundred million
give me a
break you know this is this is just
people having a low opinion of law
lawyers enforced when this kind of thing
happens so
Le representa Lehman for a comment thank
you uh thank you Mr chairman do you know
what remains in the settlement fund at
this
point uh well we've had an appro
appropriation change over if you will
I'm not sure that's the right
terminology um so there the first 100
million that was appropriated um that
has been um expended through um award or
expenses um and then the um next
appropriation is the 60 million and I do
not have status right now of where we
are at the 60 million but that is
something that we're working on as part
of this transitionary period is making
sure we know exactly where we are with
the 60 million as
well okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman okay so we have voted to pass
the item and and we'll be in further
conversation we will be expecting to
send forth a lot of questions to the
attorney general someone should have
been here to answer them and obviously
that we have to have a special meeting
just to proove what does come forward
from the attorney general and and your
office so thank you for being here and
and taking care of this mess as best you
can yes we'll do it together anything
further this lady seeing none thank you
all right number two is old business
I'll recognize Senator rosenal thank
thank you Mr chairman I recommend we
take the old item off the table and
replace it with FIS
24-
227 all right Motion in a second to to
move it off 20 the old item off the
table and replace it with FIS 24227 is
there any further discussion on that
motion seeing none you're ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
we'll remove that item from the table
and I see the Chief Financial Officer
here um to discuss or answer any
questions on on the item that was before
us and brief us on the
change Mr White
welcome thank you chairman wer uh
members of the committee Nathan white
chief chief financial officer with the
Department of Health and Human Services
um the difference between the the tabled
item and the item sitting before you
is the removal of approximately
$35,000 of opioid abatement funds that
were to be earned um Senator Rosen Wald
and myself had a number of conversation
conversations around this and we thought
the best path forward at this point in
time would be to move the item forward
uh without the inclusion of those funds
at this point um and I can pause there
unless you like a higher level overview
of the item thank you questions from the
members
seeing none is there a motion
item motion and a second to approve the
item
24227 is there any further discussion
seeing none are you ready for the
question all in favor say I I oppose no
motion is adopted so we will meet again
I see Mr Caine run away but Pam will
tell us it's the 17th is was that the
decided date August 16th I'm sorry
August 16th we will hope to have all the
information to deal further with this
item and and move it along yes fiscal at
10 o'clock on Friday the 16th of August
is there any problem with any of the
members here
schedule and I'll entertain a motion to
adjourn
motion and a second to to adjourn is
there any fur and seeing no further
discussion all in favor say I oppos no
adjourned